can you talk about your training
schedules rolls which is jiu-jitsu
training sessions called was that for me
you explain to me what rolls is for
everyone all right all right in the
event of them not knowing we'd be
rolling so can you talk about your
training schedules your rolls and what
is a typical week what does that look
like well for me you know I work out
every day so what that means every
morning I wake up early and I get it on
I lift weights I do calisthenics I do
some kind of sprinting evolution
seven days a week seven days a week and
and as I've explained to many people on
the Twitter they say don't you ever take
a day off and I do but I don't plan to
take days off days off life brings days
off you got the broken water heater you
got the sick kids you got sick you got
the the car broke down
you got the event at school whatever it
is some there's some reason there's some
travel plans that don't allow it so
there's life will give you days off so
don't take off days voluntarily don't do
that let the days off come through life
and then then you don't have to freak
out about them you just go oh cool I got
a day off day to rest cool I'm gonna
travel or I'm gonna you don't wanna miss
a workout today just gonna take it as a
day of rest so but I do I work out every
day and part of that is going off of
instinct of what I feel like of what
type of workout I'm gonna do and and by
that sometimes I mean I don't feel like
doing a certain kind of workout
therefore I'm going to do it because
it's punishment for being weak and then
there's times where I'm like you know
what I do not want to do that kind of
workout today because I feel an
impending injury oh yeah you know like
hey I'm gonna lift real heavy today no
not today
I'm tight I'm sore I'm gonna not do that
type of workout today so it's a little
combination of instinct and discipline
versus freedom of you know what this is
gonna be too much for you today I don't
want to lift heavy today or I don't feel
it sometimes I feel like lifting heavy
you know in other words I may be drained
I'm drained to do some kind of an
endurance type or workout or a metcon so
it's gonna go in there and just just do
some singles and but then some days you
feel you know I'm man I don't feel like
putting any heavy weight up today I'm
gonna go in there and do something
lighter but maybe higher repetitions and
that type of things so I'm doing that
every day you know calisthenics
sometimes I'm doing a combination of all
three sometimes I'm doing one so that's
just just how I'm getting after it and
again I think at some point I'm gonna
write an e-book because the publishing
process and the publishing world's a
real pain and the ebooks not in the book
an e-book is easier it's easier to do
you do it you produce it you just put it
through Amazon and Amazon just says oh
cool you sell them we don't I could sew
them for like 3 bucks and then anyone
can watch them could just get it and it
doesn't have to be I don't feel bad if I
don't you know if it's not the it's
something that I could do the way I
wanted to do I don't have to I left them
like enough to make it a certain length
like no it's man it's 3 bucks
you know it's 28 pages that's the
information I have it's not you know if
someone said hey chocolate once you to
write a fitness book then that's got to
be a hundred and twenty seven pages and
it's gotta have a bunch of things in it
that I don't want to talk about cuz it's
not that complicated
right so 27 pages ebook download it
print it out everybody can have it cost
three bucks
people are stoked we're all good people
can stop asking me what my workouts are
like because everybody wants to know
that I don't know why I'm not you know
some incredible athlete you know so
here's my workouts and so that's what
I'm thinking of doing um then again
that's that's I've been thinking about
actually getting someone and saying hey
you seem like a capable human help me
write a little ebook I'm gonna tell you
what to put in it and you do it why so
it like sounds dope or what no no no
just so it gets done because right now
I'm just busy right too busy for the
fitness ebook right now yeah so I gotta
move that up I gotta move that up on my
chart because I know people want to get
out that okay so then on top of the
working out
there's this surfing which if there's
waves I'm surfing right that's just the
way it goes if there's good ways I'm
surfing there's not always good waves
but if there's waves I'm surfing one
thing I need to do more of is just go
out and paddle I need to do that we'll
just go out so you're constantly in
shape because paddling paddling a
surfboard is different kind of
conditioning more than anything else
yeah just to be in shape for battling
kind of like I've been saying hey if you
want to get good humping a rucksack then
just hump a rucksack and if you want to
get good at doing pose to pose well if
you want to be good at paddling a
surfboard
you got a paddle a surfboard so you
always feel weak when the big waves come
and you haven't surfed in a while and
you feel weak because you haven't been
paddling you lack the discipline so I
should be paddling more and then we get
to the the jujitsu the role the jujitsu
so our role if home I'm going to the gym
and I'm training you know we usually do
some technique I usually get a little
something from Jeff or from Dean and you
know Dean and Jeff the what's crazy is
you can always learn something and it
still freaks me out you know because
it's not like when I say learn something
I'm not like saying that they're
teaching me some new variation to the
gogoplata right ya know they're teaching
like Dean will say hey when you put the
guillotine on over here make this
adjustment or when you're passing the
guard do this here like some simple
thing or Jeff or Geoff clever was I said
hey Jeff teach my son though the Darce
choke and I just watched him give my son
you know like a seven minute class on
the Darce choke now my son you know
can you imagine you're getting you're
nine years old and you're getting it
personal class on the Darce joke from
Jeff Glor but my son you know he just
thinks that's normal but I'm watching
him and I remember Jeff was just going
over little details nice stuff that I
did not know chuckle relearning the
Darcys we learn in the Darce choke and
so there's always these little things
and I always I'm surprised at the
obvious nosov the things and actually
does happen occasionally in the other
direction
you know Dean was going through a slump
he's really having a hard time passing
my guard and I just said hey man you've
been doing why just do X and he you can
see I saw his face cuz he has a mutant
grappling mind like I saw his face as
soon as I told him that it was like
being it was a connection made and he
instantly started past my guard again
damn but see ya but yeah you get these
little obvious things you get the you
get the the learning so you're always
trying to learn a little something and
then you know there's the situational
drills of going in and then there's then
there's the reality here's the reality
man I like to roll yeah I like to roll
that's the reality of it
I enjoy training not starting I not
starting in one position and going in to
know I like to Train that's what I like
to do that's what I love about jiu-jitsu
so I like to roll and I roll and
whenever I go in my goal is to roll in
the same way that I will some nights I
go in like there was somebody as I go in
or nice and and you know normal night I
just feel like rolling start going in
roll some days I'm like you know what
man I'm not feeling it today mm-hmm and
because I'm not feeling it today I'm
gonna get it on and I'll force myself
that kind of that's kind of like when
your kid and you start crying or
something and your dad tells you a I'll
give you something to cry about
yeah I really feel like it oh you don't
feel like it I'll give you something to
not feel good or whatever that's right
it is that and and like a couple weeks
ago I said to my I got there and I did
not feel like rolling and I said to
myself I'm not gonna stop until
everybody stops and so you know the last
you know we start with 20 guys on the
mat and then after three rounds there's
you know 15 guys or 16 guys on the mat
and then it down to ten and then eight
and then four and then it's me and one
other guy I'm like it looks like it's
you got the last round my friend but I
just did that to myself it's a little
form of it's a little form of exercising
a little discipline but that being said
there's
is where I go in and I don't feel it and
I don't feel it as a different sense
that I have which is today's not gonna
be your date today I'm going to tweak
something today I'm - I'm - wore down or
whatever and so i'll go i'll do i'll do
some rolls and then I'll just I'll just
leave it at that you know i won't i
won't force myself to stay on the mat
forever so i do again I use that
instinct of of what I am feeling to make
a decision on how it's gonna go down
this place one day Greg he randomly I
came in he was like yeah I feel like I
just feel like I'm gonna break my toe
today yeah he said that yeah I feel like
oh yeah you just feel that he's like
yeah I just feel like it that day I
broke my toe mm-hmm I didn't really
break it it was like kind of did you
there's something like that but it's
what that's weird right
I know way different point but still so
my workouts I'll go through it real fast
different than yours I work out average
5 days a week but they're not everything
all in one so oh if I roll three days
I'll lift and do mat content cardio and
that kind of stuff two days really yeah
so hey so I don't do like what do you do
with all your free time man make videos
that's right so you really how many
times a week do you train three jitsu
three sometimes two unless I'm like
super busy and then one day yeah but
yeah back when I was competing I was
doing six yeah now it's like two days
not today straight but I'll do running
lifting conditioning yeah and then a
different session I do jujitsu and
whatever you know that entails same
thing as you you know do some technique
but I'll typically hey how many rounds
deep it like on a typical day
you know how you'll do some technique
liftable class or training session even
you'll do some technique maybe some
drills at 6:00 and then rounds right so
you do six rounds that's solid what five
minutes six six six six minute rounds
you just kind of like whatever it's yeah
it's strange because that's one
and we did like a the we had the gym was
closed but we had you know an open mat
but wasn't it open that was like hey
we're gonna train yeah and we did wait
we who just a bunch of guys you were
probably there I don't know I don't
remember but we did six six minute
rounds
nogi and then six six minute rounds gear
yeah
I usually don't get tired yeah I got
tired that day well I got tired that day
yeah the house it okay so I I'd go to I
haven't been taught this in not a few
months now but um I'd go there like when
they're between for ADCC and I'd go
there once a week once every two weeks
just for one and so they do stuff like
it every single time I've been there
it's been one of these things ten to six
tenths six rounds of ten minutes each
thirty seconds in between one and then
one minute between the next one you know
and go say or five ten minute rounds oh
no for ten minute minute rounds and then
one twenty minute round those you get
tired yeah sure I have conditioning
because when we do twenty like when I'm
when Dean's get ready for ECC or whoever
we got that's doing the longer or the no
time limit matches and I'm doing 20
minutes 20 minutes I'm just good to go
in yeah I surprised my handled what I
did it but I think it has to do with
what we talked about the other day where
I'm not a really fast sprinter right and
I'm not a really fast runner but if you
put a rucksack on me I can go for a long
time and I think it's one of those like
I can grapple for a long time yeah not
get tired yeah I think mine
psychological where if I know it's 20
minutes then I'm not I don't feel like I
don't know come find or I don't know I
feel like we're just you know the
hardest thing that we do is really was
like when we Shark Tank each other you
know is when you're putting you know
I'll be or one of our guys that's
competing will go in the middle and
you're getting a fresh guy every yeah
two minutes one minute three minutes
five minutes whatever the case may be
you're getting somebody fresh on you and
that's where you get that's where you
get tested yeah I would say a typical
class though is like anywhere from a
five minute round six minute round
either five or six minutes three four or
four rounds I'd say that's a typical you
know not at not a training for
competition just you know this is what
we're doing if you go four five six
rounds that's like that's kind of a lot
of rounds compared to just the average I
think in my experience yeah I like I
sort I feel like I got I got good
training yet like six six better rounds
that's what I feel good yes that's 36
yeah it's almost forty forty something
minutes of training that makes me feel
good yeah
yeah that's a lot that's a lot though
you know you'll see you guys dropping on
yeah after three rounds oh yeah not
everybody obviously it has to do with
who you're training with yes yeah
because it means everything I get
trained with somebody that's not that
good all day long right but you get to
start getting the grinders on you yeah
got to be ready oh and I've trained with
Andy one round yeah one man is like
literally like three rounds within like
an average normal person on your level
yeah he's pace in the Strang what's cool
about any was Andy is he's he's probably
my main training partner now
all the time but for a while he didn't
work out at all he didn't like lift her
knee right yeah back in the day and then
I said hey man you got to get to the
next level I hate to say it you got to
do some working out you know and he's an
athletic guy in yes and I just said hey
go do a bunch of pull-ups then the next
day do bunch of push-ups and dips and
the next day to do some squats mm-hmm
and he's okay he started doing it and in
a month man he was a different dude yeah
and now we started powerlifting so he's
even he's even morphing a little bit
more but he's won some Big D's won some
big tournaments got some game yeah sure
he did good and then in the challenges
League metamours challenge yeah if he
took second yeah yeah he's great partner
yes funny he was I noticed that where he
was always athletic and stuff and then
one time I hadn't seen him for not that
long but like before we take him Ross
ain't what you know what did you do
because you look way different right now
and he was like oh I just changed my
eating I don't eat like whole containers
of Nutella anymore
yeah that's it